simply learn job guarantee program  guaranteed start to career success over  a period of two years i didn't work it  was a career gap for me i moved on to  bangalore then this lockdown happened  and the score with 19 and everything  came to a halt so the data science  course with simply learn offers had the  best reviews and i've gone through the  syllabus and that's what i wanted at  that moment of time so eventually i  joined this company said as a lead  assistant manager because the role which  they were offering was pretty much  aligned with the course which i have  done like a non job secure your next job  today the guaranteed way ahead